welcome to this video round one the
candidates encanta man Sisk and this is
coverage for the game this year anand
the former world champion against Levon
Aronian probably my most chess fans
considered to be the favorite to win
this tournament to become the next
Challenger for the world title but this
is certainly not an easy game for Romeo
Allen term really had very bad streak of
results over the last year's even at
this candidates tournament I'm actually
surprised that he took part in it but
yeah you know he's known as the tiger
tiger from Chennai the wounded tigers
you know okay so it's not so easy and
let's see what happens
we should playing e4 and there's no
surprise in the opening aronia is really
one of those guys who sticks to his
openings he does not surprise people
much with the black pieces especially he
plays some the double king pony 45 for
most of his career and sticks to it so
you could easily predict this position
to appear on the board aronia is an
expert on the the marshal attack which
we would get after these moves in fact
only recently we had a game in the
marshal that Aronian Lost's black
against kawana but it's not so common
nowadays that white players actually
allow the marshal they very often after
castles go for one of those entire
marshals or even deviate before that so
now the most popular move in top-level
chess is h3 and this is what Anand
played the reason is that if black now
plays d5
did this position comparable to the real
marshal let's say why displayed the move
h3 which is most of the times useful
instead of C's instead of C 3 and C 3 is
really a move that you don't like so
much in this position because it hampers
your development here white even has the
opportunity to just put out the night
and it's considered to be insufficient
for black in fact for for a very long
time
after Bishop to b7 d3 it was believed
that black now is almost obliged to play
you know in a way that it is more common
in the very close to sing in the Chico
rain and the the Brian to play something
like d6 for example and after let's say
a 3 do something like 98 one of those
slow you know pests type maneuvering
games but a couple of years ago in fact
it came to to the forefront that even
here d5 is a playable movement Aronian
is playing it so is going for for for
pawn sacrifice after all which yeah I'm
slightly surprised about to be honest I
mean he has played he has played this
before it's not like it's sensational
that he's sacrificing the pawn here as
well but first round of such an
important tournament not sure if you
really should play it yeah play play
line that has some some inherent risk to
it at least in my book giving up a pawn
for eco Scott copied he will get
compensation no doubt but he also could
have chosen a more conservative approach
with d6 aw it's also the move through p8
if you want to vary here ok I'm not
criticizing it but I was surprised that
I went for this pawn sec after all here
why it takes after 95 the most columns
nowadays is actually what yeah I mean 95
and that standards phrase it differently
95 is the most apparent truth and this
isn't so popular anymore
Black has two ways to play he can take
here play Queen to d6 rook here and
something like yeah was he five we have
a position where black can has got some
compensation based on active pieces good
development and good central control
it's still a pawn but it's as
compensation this is the first type of
position and the other and this is I
think even more reliable this is 95 90
form here very black very often gets the
bishop pay off by capturing on b3 and
here the compensation is some it's a bit
of more of a long-term nature because
you can rely on your bishop pair as
compensation for the poem this is as
mentioned not so popular anymore Anna
displaying Knight B to d2 which he has
played before in fact last year against
kawana so we see the top players they
play on openings
how many openings from both sides yeah
what did Cara wanna play him he played
f6 last year f6 weird looking because
you sort of open up the diagonal but
there are no tactics and yeah you just
keep your paws which is also sometimes
nice to not play a pawn down all the
time
in fact koala got a very decent position
after c3 he just went to h8 make sure
that there's nothing terrible happening
on the long diagonal and he enjoyed a
pretty
position he actually won the game later
but this did not really have anything
concrete to do with the opening but this
is a decent alternative that black can
choose and Aronian himself he had this
position as black some years ago against
Mickey Adams and he played Knight to f4
actually a means that I like because
it's it's just more concrete and puts
the knight on an active square putting
some pressure on g2 so that white for
instance cannot consider to take him
yeah note that g2 black might start with
that and then take g2 so this is not on
at all
so black here has two very decent
alternatives here but surprisingly
Aronian played to the move Queen d7 and
he played it relatively quickly and this
in fact at least in my database as a
novelty on maybe there is some very new
game or obscure game that actually
helped this move featured before but I
didn't I didn't find any any example and
tournament practice of the smooth so
what is it doing it is it's just giving
up the pawn I mean how else can you can
you take can you call it I mean white is
taking it now he does not have any great
prep moves available anyway so he took
it and of course now with the Queen
hanging you need to take on e5 there's
no way to go ninety four takes rook
takes and now Knight f6 being played and
this is a completely different setup
that our own ian is is is playing here
he withdraws the night and goes for a
further of future Bishop to d6
and I don't really like it to be honest
I mean it feels like he has some
compensation
later but at least from my personal
tastes a horse what to put the night
back on d5 try to get it to a forever
I will show you later what what I'm what
I'm referring to add so I don't really
like that that set up it probably should
be okay in terms of compensation black
has very good free piece play but I
don't I don't really think this is any
better than the already already known
moves and in those you know you're not
even a pawn down I mean I mean yeah it's
maybe a matter of taste if you give me a
choice to have a decent position with
equal material or a decent position
being one pawn down I'll take it with
equal material so um the thing is look
what happens
I want withdraws the rook rook e8 93
this is very logical and one reason
behind this 92 early you want to get it
to f3 and now Bishop d6 this is
obviously the setup that Aronian was
sourced looking for and our Bishop e3
was played so why does completing its
development it's clear that like has
some compensation is also a case of of a
space advantage it's not like a space
advantage is supported by pawns
sometimes it's just like that you have
those advanced pawns that temper you
have
opponents some ability to move but here
it's also based on pieces the black
pieces control lots of the center and
you have got those very excellent Bishop
so I'm not saying that black is without
any compensation I'm just saying that
here my choice of the move would be
ninety five and well we had he moved it
back from d5 just a couple of moves ago
and it's filled some somewhat we act
but okay this is my suggestion to play
for black Iranian plate and another myth
and this is what probably I would have
done it has the simple idea to to get
one of the bishops by taking here or to
get to 2 F 4 maybe even supported by
Queen a5 just to get the pieces active
get near the king and and activate this
is some my suggestion I don't think that
black is in terrible shape here I mean
if White's
secure says Bishop for example then
black could go could play something like
that let's say c5 and yeah what not what
must be cautious in a way if you do
something like that
let's say here Knight f4 and then you
take yeah you ignore all this then black
already is in time to sacrifice on h3
with a bang and this yam is even an
instant kill white will lose badly on
the King many threats many threats f3
hangs Bishop h2 check
so yeah I would have tried to go to get
something going like that of course and
it's not allowing the sacrifice and and
everything but yeah it feels like what
Aronian is doing is somewhat slow he
played rookie 7d for yeah makes sense
and now look f28 this yeah I mean of
course you have improved your position
by by doubling but I feel it didn't help
so much
now c3 it's let's know what is improving
is position slowly and now h6 playing a
slow move again and I feel like here you
really need to play 95 get something
concrete going maybe I have too
impatient I'm not I'm not patient enough
but I don't I don't really see the
compensation if you if you move around
so much you need to I mean
with black setup you already have four
faded the idea to play c5 quickly which
is helpful normally to gain some space
on the queenside
and yeah I think you need to do that
yeah to get the bishops on or something
if wide retreats you at least can go
here and then sort of threatened again
here not sure how much of a threat it
really is but yeah you have some
activity probably white is forced to
take this this night off at some point
and then you at least have the the
bishop pair for your pawn you know this
was played and and now I think Allen is
just just better I mean you cannot argue
anymore
after ninety five black is which is a
strong move by the way black is forced
to take I mean you cannot tolerate the
knight on only five if you move the the
Queen for example you must even reckon
yeah I don't know what's best here
really supporting it with the bishop or
with the pawn it both looks good yeah
you need to take it you cannot tolerate
this annoyed and look at this now after
the capture yeah like takes here only
five and white exchanges Queens now we
have a simplified position now but look
at this look at this
mighty Scott the bishop pair and this is
the bad thing it's the combination of
the two things White has the bishops and
black has weakened to the Queen side and
he has this typical rule Oh past
formation with a six b5 and c7 where you
have multiple weaknesses on c7 on c6
possibly on a6 and this is a problem
here if black just for argument's sake
would have the pawn on d6 and said Oh b5
then the position is not nice to play
but very solid for black but here white
has this long-term edge of the bishop
pair
plus the ideas to play against the
weakened pawns on the queenside
and this is I feel already already too
much I think Black has really really
hard time here on our plate logical move
rookie to d1 and Aronian responded with
Knight f6 at first I thought that maybe
Knight c5 here would be a good idea to
try to get this this bishop but white
can just capture it and play route e7 so
just a concrete sequence that secures
White's advantage on f7 you are simply a
guy you cannot force a move like that
what is just all over you so yeah
probably you give a pawn and now why
Chan what can can gain a pawn here and
and continue from there with the idea
here
h5 Bishop to 6 why does gain the pawn
and and this is better but yeah it's
it's it's sad to tell I mean this is a
very bad position I'm not sure that the
game is also very bad after c4 what
should like do here the move that that
Aronian now plays looks yeah extremely
ugly but it's not apparent what what
else he should do yeah
what is what should like - it's very
tricky and one idea that I had is to
regroup this Bishop I mean it always was
a good piece when combined with the
Knight to f4 and the Queen to attack
here but now with Queens off this is
completely pointless this piece only on
b7 I thought maybe you can try something
like that to neutralize the b3 bishop
but let's look Luke c1 this threatens to
take and take on c7 and yeah who is
black going to to keep
this poor now let's say place like that
why would you stake and long-term
pressurize the spawn that's an awful
position to defend white can improve
further with the bishop to deform yeah
maybe this is a bit tough I mean c6 is
just so ugly but it's already very very
uncomfortable for black note that also
the time was largely in favor of
volunteer
I mean to be honest I only played like
seven moves of our movie eleven was the
novelty so I'm sorry like 11 moves from
this they've they play on their own but
it wasn't like difficult to play the
moves especially from the white side but
I'm really unsure how Iranian yeah
avoided this 95 odd years all the time I
mean I'm not a I'm I must admit that I'm
not a terribly a great expert on this
pawn sacrifice lines in the room I never
played the Marshall for example I play
the real opuses black for ages but I
don't play the the Marshall and maybe
I'm judging this wrong but I just felt
that he he didn't push hard enough to to
get some real compensation him yeah it
here
it's very one-sided I mean and
completely logical what was she is doing
I mean you can talk about his his yeah
bad run bad shape whatever if you give
him an excellent position he will win it
and yeah this is just very bad for black
the dead Bishop the weaknesses and the
two bishops on the white side he now
decided to take it's very difficult not
to take I mean there are all kinds of
ideas to improve White's position he
took and put the night there this was my
idea for defense of
okay white of course keeps the the
bishop on the board this is such a
strong piece on c5 rook moves and now f3
white stripes for total control here the
bishop cm I accidentally placed and you
will try to win those two pawns and you
know look at this a very nice maneuver I
know it is at the moment protected but
that's a general idea you might be able
to make this knight move away from
defile
no here it goes what a charity but we
can try without that if like yeah like
let's say it just plays the sit and wait
strategy you have many other ideas you
can also think about about this at the
right moment and that's not that's
simply not a great position white can
also start with that and have rook b8 in
mind yeah this is actually what I like
best
it looks quite quite straightforward
yeah this is what was played Luke b3 and
rook d8 trying to get some play on d2
but white is just retreating and putting
it on D to wear important squares we
important squares like those of the
night are covered yeah Knight f6 back
and rupee eight yo black simply has no
defense you can look at it for for a
longer period of time if you if you like
but those two others just just terribly
weak and after a couple of moves here
okay
I'm sorry this was too quick
here in fact it's an interesting
position what what why should do I think
there should be five was there was a
good solution you can also take him but
let's look at this what will she was
doing here exactly this position
here it's interesting because I was I
was watching this life learned the live
from the broadcast and he took 13
minutes on this move amazingly tried to
probably work it out almost to the end
here the most apparent means is rook
takes c6 and I was surprised that he
didn't play it because it looks so
excellent if black takes here you will
play Bishop to d4 and by this way
dominate the knight on e4 which is yeah
about to get strapped with b3 this was
also very strong line and of course
black has other ways to play can take
here and try to defend this position but
will also be in vain this pawn will get
lost as well if black tries to keep it
you have have this additional
possibility and here I mean more than
one way to win but you can even just go
check go to this endgame and when it is
a leave this is the winning pawn at the
end yeah Bishop to 2d form and this is
in fact also a pretty clear win the tech
here and this is what which she probably
calculated to the end that this is
actually showed before this is almost
trapped and we now see that it is
strapped with precise play rook d8 rook
see for attacking in the night covered
b3 yeah what now black only has one move
to to continue in a way Bishop to b5
look to defer to before and it still it
has no square
don't like a plate bishop - I had night
to be - which is still a funny idea if
you don't get this check cause need to
be alert yeah but white can just take on
b5 and this seals the deal the thing is
that after 8xb
5 white has this king moves and this
keeps the knight trapped it has no way
to go anywhere now this is threatened so
yeah I think if this gave this checks
and after king c3 Aronian resigned the
game so we have a decisive result in
this game surprisingly I was
it's a typical drawing game I thought
before the round but and surprisingly
had won this game and Aronian really
played played a somewhat strange games I
thought for the playoff his strengths
it's somewhat it looked somewhat very
yeah
there was no decisiveness in his play if
you sacrifice this pawn early I thought
that you should really yeah try to get
more activity out of your position and
try to be more straightforward about you
play maybe I'm judging this wrong but it
felt like all the time to to go for
something like that and and to get some
activity maybe he had some some
miscalculation here that he believed
that this 95 idea wasn't so dangerous
and I'm not sure I didn't see any press
conference or statement of the of the
players that might um gas shed some
light on this on this subject
yeah I thought that this was a bit bit
strange
to what
I played here a very good start
obviously for Honor's who really yeah
got some yeah got some good good you got
lots of criticism in the last couple of
month and very often people said well
okay
you shouldn't even play and so on you
know has no chance and whatever I
actually I didn't really think he
shouldn't play I was only surprised that
he's doing it because well it felt like
it's maybe a good a good spot to you
have to to call it a day in terms of
ambition to become the world champion
again because after all I mean you play
this tournament to win it and if you win
it you get get madness again and what he
got yeah it was a pretty clear firm last
year so um yeah I don't know still I
mean I'm playing chess for like I was 25
years and in 24 years of those I'm a fan
of aren't and I mean not like he's my
one number one favorite player but he
always was a very strong play and simply
nice guy to to to follow so I'm glad
that he maybe is getting a good
tournament whether it's going to be a
win for him this whole thing or for for
anybody else I just fell feel like it's
a good thing that he that he is not
getting like a disastrous result again
yeah of course on the other hand I was
really hoping that yeah let's say I'm
hoping that one of the big guns like
Aronian or Kramnik will win this thing
to give Magnus a good fight so it's a
bit disappointing that respect to see
Aronian losing but okay it's a long
tournament this fourteen rounds total
this is only the first round and last
year we saw in London that a plus three
result was good enough to to go through
which
I know +3 seems a little bit modest
maybe plus four but let's say plus four
result is good enough then aronia needs
to win five games out of 13 left which
is certainly doable for a player of his
some strengths but still you've lost the
game in the first round and it's awful
to do some alright so an interesting
fight nevertheless and yeah thanks for
watching and let's see what happens in
one - bye